Hunter do you have a day job outside of
filmmaking I actually do not have a day
job and it's taken me a while to get to
this point where I think for the last
two now three years I've not had a day
job but I think about day jobs sometimes
I definitely have those moments where
I'm like well maybe I'll go back and dip
in and take some easy cash for a little
while but not at this point I don't at
what moments do you entertain that idea
it depends I mean it's definitely
moments of frustration when you know you
you work very hard to raise a bunch of
money for Walter for example and you
know we did a crowdfunding campaign we
raised $25,000 and and we spent it all
very fast you know it's basically
accounted for but it was sort of our
strategy with how we're gonna release
this film and once you put that money
back out there into the system you
definitely have these moments where
you're like gosh it's just too easy to
spend this money and you know we're
we're you know looking at how long it'll
take for the money to start coming back
it's a calculated sort of gamble that
would that we face but you have these
moments where you go through the process
and you see what the industry is really
like and you see how much competition is
out there and how much content is out
there and you're like hmm is it really
worth all this energy that we're not
only that we're contributing but now
that others through crowd you know
crowdfunding and and you know a fan base
is supporting to really you know keep
keep after it you know for what what you
get in return
so you know you have those moments that
just creep up on you and then something
inevitably happens where you calm down
and you know you something something
comes your way and all of a sudden
you're like gosh you sit down a lot of
times it's sitting down and seeing an
audience watch your film and feeling it
really have the effect that it's
supposed to or you get this wonderful
email or a conversation that you had
with somebody that sort of turned you
back around and makes you realize it's
like this is for whatever reason this is
what I was put on this this earth to do
and I got
making these films so we have now five
films under your belt
at what point of those five films were
you able to walk away from a day job so
I have five films I've directed and
there's been another one I produce with
Mike Dion called reveal the path and it
was about the time that Mike and I came
together on ride the divide that I was I
was actually thinking I was done for
sure and I was working a day job and or
I was getting ready to work a day job I
was kind of shifting things up and so I
shot this film with Mike ride the divide
and I was like okay this will maybe be
my last hoorah
you know get out there this was number
three number two was a total bomb and I
was like I'll go shoot this enjoy this
moment and then go work and you know
work the agency life and see where it
takes me but I remember stepping into
that agency life and I kind of put one
foot in and kept one foot out and I was
like I really don't want to work
full-time so I set up a nice social
structure where I was essentially
working full time but I was contract
position and it it's still that time
though I figured you know this is
probably going to be the way it goes but
over time as ride the divide came out
and was released
you know we saw quite a bit of success
with that film and that was about the
time where I think I felt that you know
I got to just get out there again and
give it another go that was probably it
really wasn't until we saw that film
take off but I had that feeling that I
could I could do this full-time but I
realized that if I do it full-time I
have to do it full-time and more than
full-time you know tell makers will work
in every hour we can trying to get this
this content made looking good and then
ultimately distributed them and marketed
so you know you still have to check in
every once long ago okay breathing
there's actual money coming in from the
titles that I made in the past you know
we're figuring out a system to do this
but it's it's not easy it's not easy
money that's for sure and
it's usually just enough to kind of get
by and you're kind of fun and all the
ways you can to to continue shortcutting
so fortunately it took that one one
title that ride the divide that kind of
gave gave us you know gave me enough
sort of confidence in myself but also
you know a little bit of cash flow and
then and then you know being smart about
my next few titles and not overspending
and finding ways to make sure they get
to market and that they you know also
continue to give a little bit of revenue
stream to to our to my approach I find
cash flow is like instant confidence
yeah it really is so what would you
advise to another filmmaker who has
probably lived that 40-hour week life as
most of us have at one time and training
themselves I know we talked about it
briefly because it seems like it if I
remember correctly from some videos I
watched you were close to going back
before you did Walter yeah yeah for sure
I mean it's you have to keep questioning
you know why you're doing this is it
worth it is is that are the sacrifices
you make unfortunately the the corporate
world that you see around you that so
many of your friends are are investing
in you know and getting return for you
know is is tempting at times just
because you see people living this life
where they get things and they buy
things they consume you know but that's
not necessarily the right lifestyle for
everybody that's certainly not going to
guarantee happiness it's not gonna you
know fulfill you if you're somebody who
needs to be creative and needs to tell
stories and has these thoughts that you
feel are important for the time and
that's and if you if you ignore those if
you're one of those people and you're
ignoring that you ultimately you know
dip into that corporate system you know
it's not you know it's not necessarily
going to to deliver that happiness so I
think I got off-track I'm I'm uh you
know trying to try to remember the exact
question but ultimately oh no no I think
that's though it's a great point that
you did talk about because maybe these
people do need to kind of be able to buy
what they need to buy and
like okay I'm kind of bored now this is
not I don't know if I want to turn my
life over for this many hours yeah just
so I can buy stuff yeah but I think the
initial question I had was oh how would
you change or how would you train
someone or not train them but advise
them from making that shift because it's
one thing to like say oh I'm gonna cut
back I'm gonna cut out cable I'm gonna
not go to Starbucks and things like that
but there's some drastic mindset changes
I think you have to make right so it's
it's not just going without the morning
latte I think you have to trust in
things
yeah for sure I think if you really want
to make films you have to realize that
you're going to give a lot to that and
you're going to put a ton of time and
probably have to cut a lot of things out
of your life and at some point you'll
get lucky and at some point you know
you'll work hard enough that the return
will start to come for me it's a matter
of it I look at film as a long-term
investment I think most people look at
it as a short-term investment it's not
your first project it shouldn't you know
you're not likely to have that one-hit
wonder
and take off and totally have this
career that said that it's extremely
unlikely and it's something that we
should be all dreaming about dreaming
about and it will happen to a few but
for most of us it's going to be
something that we really need to take a
lot of time with and find a way to have
a lifestyle that allows you to keep
producing films for some people that is
the day job and for me it was at times
and I never discount it it may be again
there may be a point where I say I need
to go back and and work a day job for a
little while and just have that
experience and that might my mind rest
from having to always you know
compensate make it happen has it gotten
easier for you from the third to the
fourth I mean in terms of trusting in
that process because I think so many
people have that mindset where oh it's
gonna be this one and that's all I'm
gonna need and then I could just you
know wave goodbye or some other gesture
to my old life
uh-huh but has it gotten easier or is it
so scary because now you know the
realities of it you know it definitely
gets a little easier going from film to
but what gets you know more worrisome in
this and this time is like the market
changes like you feel it happening like
there was a time early on when I was
releasing films digitally and getting
great attention for that as you've seen
with YouTube and the amount of views
that 10 miles per hour god I mean it was
the first feature-length documentary on
YouTube and so when I took those risks
like it was awesome because people are
like well check this out I got so much
attention nowadays it's harder to get
that attention because there's so many
other like films like and and and
filmmakers that are sort of like you
know propping up and trying different
things and getting sort of a little more
riskier in their approach it's kind of
but that's fun too because it's like
this anything-goes
moment you know and in the film in the
film world but so I enjoy that I embrace
it but I do get to that point where I
don't know if what I did last film was
gonna work again this film you know even
when it comes to like raising money
before a film like I've traditionally
gone to sponsors and found you know
corporate sponsors or nonprofit sponsors
to come on board and get excited about a
film concept and help essentially fund
that film and that takes the edge off of
me quite a bit because then I don't have
to worry about either dipping into my
own own money or using too much of my
and you know sweat time to like go out
and totally shoot shoot a film and make
a film so um those old tricks
they don't always stick around you know
in this day and age when films changing
so fast so you're reinventing the wheel
it sounds like everything every each
time you go out and do that you yeah you
do have to reinvent the wheel and
something I'm realizing is you each film
that I make tends to go to different
sort of audience and I like that I like
that creative ability to to change my my
approach on these stories I don't want
to necessarily just make cycling films I
don't want to get branded as that bad
guy and so but I love making those films
that I've worked with Mike on those
before
but when you you make a new film like
now we're made a film about the world's
oldest people and it's like okay who are
you gonna market this to you know some
of the same lessons and things we know
from the past don't necessarily apply to
this new sort of genre and this approach
that that we have to face so that's
that's the tricky part and while that's
fun and challenging it can be a little
daunting too if someone said hey under
can I take you out for coffee or dinner
and I'm about to leave my day job I can
you just can you talk me through it
because I'm really scared I have this
good gig but I'm not fulfilled and I've
gotten insurance and and I really I've
got some money set aside they take you
to a nice place you sit down what would
you tell them I would say leave your day
job if you're thinking about it because
there's more day jobs to come and unless
we all crash which we all do it together
there's going to continue to be jobs as
far as I'm concerned if you're self a
self think you're a motivator you know
somebody who's motivated and can make
stuff happen then take your chance to
leave your day job I think we'll all
ultimately maybe know when to go back I
hope I I say that to the night caution I
throw a little caution out there because
I have had that moment back in 2008 when
everything was crashing and I was kind
of in that I don't know films for me and
I started looking a little bit at jobs
and and it's it was tough you know it
was definitely that tough feeling of
like I don't know if I can get a job
anymore I think it's it's I don't know
if I can be that sort of like here's my
resume and here's all the things I've
done sort of person you know and so I do
I would say just be careful what I say
if you do sit down with me
but seriously go for it I mean you take
take these chances this is our time in
life to get to take chances and do cool
things and you watch 10 miles per hour
and that's my principal and you know
I've met a lot of people along the way
that have seen that film and it's helped
ultimately I think effect their decision
to to quit go for something else so what
type of check lists should someone make
what it's like they almost are packing
for a camping trip if they're going
leave a day job let's suppose they
realize okay there are many other jobs
to come in my lifetime but I may not
have the time and energy that I do now
at this age so I'm gonna do it what
would you tell them what are some of the
actual like
you know whether have this much amount
of rent or mortgage in the bank or you
know I mean like real concrete mmm
steps I think if you want to leave your
job to try something new I think you
definitely should try to have some
savings set the set aside and you know
and that would depend on if you've got a
mortgage or those types of things I'd be
afraid not to I mean I would I would say
that you should kind of evaluate what
you really need what you have to have
and be okay with potentially separating
yourself from some of the things that
you're you're you know sort of hooked on
I've often found when you make those
changes in life it brings you know so
much so much reward to you and then have
a plan you know give yourself a time
timeframe for developing what you want
to do if it's a film great I mean don't
think that you can go out and make a
film in a few months it's gonna take
typically a year to two years at least
for your first film to really develop it
and shoot it and and get it finished for
some people takes a lot longer I think
it's very important to put pressure on
yourself and those that you're working
with like I try not to put I try not to
allow more than two years to span for
the whole lapse of development and you
know production and post-production and
ultimately distribution you know I mean
distribution kind of goes on but the
main core initial phase of distribution
is you know usually a few to several
months so my goal you know the minute
with films is you know definitely give
yourself a limit and that's with any any
project and if you get out there and you
quit your job you've done this and it's
not working for you don't be afraid to
go back and and work again at a day job
for a little while rethink you know
reinvent I think that too many times we
get too scared about ou know what's
gonna happen and really well be fine you
know you might be in a little bit of
financial duress for a while but who
cares you can you can use your
experiences that you've found by by
quitting your job and trying something
different to ultimately find a better
job that pays better and you can pay
things off quickly I mean I was a I was
in debt about $40,000 after my first
film and 10 miles per hour and I
when we were releasing it you know we're
making back a little bit of that money
but then we were trying to make another
film and we were trying to get out of
this hole and I was definitely stuck in
a hole of lots of debt and for me that
felt like a lot of debt at that time it
was on credit cards and I can remember
when you know we were able to use this
like kind of scheme to prevent the
interest from hitting and then the
interest started hit both Josh and I
were like yeah what are we gonna do you
know and that's that was the time when I
was like okay time a good job for a
while and I went back got a job and I
just worked very hard to pay those those
credit cards off that was my top
priority I wanted to as fast as I could
get out of that debt took took a couple
years but I was able to do it and and
that gave me a lot of life again but
there was a period of time was dark it
was hard it was like I can't make these
films this is a this is a joke well
fortunately something like 10 miles per
hour you know had a few deals and and
some some money did come in and we were
able to use the money that was coming in
to help you know to help get that debt a
little quicker that's not the case for
everybody I know sometimes your films
just don't don't seem to to hit or take
off so going from having a boss to being
your own boss how do you keep yourself
on track because I would imagine it's so
easy to get sidetracked from you're used
to punching in or being at a job and
then you're your own boss and this is
ultimately up to you how do you be your
own taskmaster so to speak like keep
yourself on track and not ya know check
Facebook every 10 minutes or yeah
keeping myself on track is definitely
one of the challenges when I work for
myself you know
partly because when you're working on a
variety of films you have films that are
in release so you're trying to promote
those then you want to develop new ideas
and then you also sometimes need to edit
a film you've got all these different
things going on in any given moment
because you you know you've got multiple
titles and you're like sometimes it's
easy to shut down or get overwhelmed so
I just have one of those minds that puts
pressure on myself and those around me
like you know sometimes I worry about my
wife who I work with on films now
because I'm constantly basically getting
up in the mornings and just a lot of
times their mental but I'm putting
together these lists of trying to make
sure each day I'm you know checking
things off those lists sometimes they're
you know in spreadsheets and a little
bit more like planned out but it's it's
very important for me to make sure that
like every day I've got I'm making some
kind of progress you know when I get a
chance to travel and I'm in a place like
LA or New York I'm trying to set up as
many meetings as I can because you never
know when a meeting might lead to an
opportunity or might might you know
might give you some new ideas or give
you some opportunities so I definitely
have to put a lot of pressure though on
myself because it's it's it's difficult
you know it's not like having a job
where you you know you walk in and
you've got your day-to-day tasks and
then you can kind of leave and and go
home so at the same time I'm also trying
to figure out how to make sure I'm not
over you know over doing things or
wasting a lot of time on stuff that's
not gonna really pan out so I'm trying
to I'm trying to look at what I'm doing
and constantly re-evaluating and
thinking about past projects and going
well did that did that really work I
found that if I set up bigger sort of
periods of time that are dedicated to
one type of thing that I'd bought more
effective so for example Walter was
essentially done and edit ready for
release and we were trying to figure out
exactly how we're gonna roll out Walter
and I was sitting around feeling like I
was not being very efficient because it
was over the summer I wasn't sure you
know when exactly we're gonna release
and so we sat down with our team and
said okay let's make a plan on whether
we're releasing but let's also design a
Kickstarter campaign crowdfunding
campaign that will help make that
release happen and really put our energy
into that crowdfunding campaign and so I
remember that period of time where I
felt in if inefficient I felt like I
really wasn't progressing and at once we
sort of had a really good solid plan
that would take over the next few months
of our life and time then it's like the
ball started rolling other meetings
started coming new you know new projects
came in there there was like a certain
sort of
that was the that came about and of
course it helped that our Kickstarter
campaign was successful takes a lot of
work but that was ultimately you know a
good example of how productivity was
back in place and you know after this
phase we got another month or so of this
phase we'll get into sort of a hop you
know holiday time it'll slow down a
little bit and so we'll see you know
we'll see sort of what the next plan may
be that would be more of a development
time where we write write out some ideas
and really focus on some things like
that but I like to kind of section off
these little periods of of the year or
whatever to really focus on one aspect
of a project speaking of energy you were
saying that in some sense things have
gotten a little bit easier and that now
you have a tremendous body of work and
then some deals or potential things have
come from it and people are interested
can you touch on that so yeah and one of
the exciting things about right now is
as I've distributed main and distributed
multiple films back-to-back I'm finally
starting to feel that sense of like a
long term investment that's really you
know paying off not just in terms of
money because it's not paying off with a
lot of money but it's paying off with
just enough money to sustain but what
we're starting to really pay off is that
I think people are seeing that I get
films made and I get them out and do
relatively well with distribution and so
people have started to to knock on my
door which is sort of a new you know a
new a new thing and it's pretty exciting
I've had you know at the pad you know
one guy that's been emailing me multiple
times and calling me like persistently
to try to get a meeting I've had
somebody reached out to me who saw ride
the divide in LA in LA TV director who
has a concept for a TV series and he's
you know he's got legit connections and
contacts and and some great actors that
he's he's worked with and also got
committed to be part of the series and
it's a cycling series ultimately so he's
interested in sort of fusing a
documentary style with sort of his
narrative approach and the you know the
old narrative approach to making a TV
deal so it's kind of a cool period of
time or it's like I can sense things are
shifting you know I can sense that
there's you know it's one of those deals
where it hasn't quite fully opened up
yet but it's nice to to feel that you
know if you really stay committed and
you make films and you're really focused
on on something that eventually you will
get people seeking you out you know and
talking to you and I mean in the
instance of this potential TV series I
know it's it's like all my other
projects all my other things I don't get
too excited because a lot of things that
a lot of these things don't pan out and
that's something you you you sort of
learn to to to do over the years is you
just you can't get overly excited you
have to take you know take everything
with a grain of salt and take your time
on it and make sure you have multiple
ideas you know in the hopper and if
something's failing and not working get
rid of it move on you know and I think I
think when you can kind of figure out
that right sort of sort of assortment of
things and energy and and people start
knocking on your doors that's that's
ideally when you know when you can kind
of say okay I've done all this for a
reason you know like it's actually gonna
potentially pay off so I'm not trying to
hopefully I'm not jinxing myself right
now but I do feel like you know we're
kind of at that turning point in the
career where some things would happen
the fact I think I watched one of your
interviews where someone said twelve
years overnight success I like shoot I'm
at almost ten years now so that means
I've got two more years and then I'll
get to be the overnight success so
waiting waiting for that day it's funny
because I remember the past that used to
be like seven years or something and
like now upset it's 12 years but
whatever I guess we're here what do you
think that other filmmakers what would
you recommend to them that they can do
to set themselves up so that they can
prove to the right people that they can
have confidence not in just their work
but also them showing up staying with
the project doing what they say they're
going to do on time because isn't that
so much of what it is they're like
they're looking for people not just who
are incredibly talented but also that
are going to be reliable or maybe I'm
wrong
ya know I think I think you learn as you
go like what kind of people are reliable
and you can sense that pretty quick if
you've got somebody who will will help
you and work with you and collaborate
and in a lot of cases like I can't pay
people what I probably should be able to
pay people but I do everything I can to
give them back in on my films and I talk
with them and I say listen this is my
approach I'm very transparent I'm doing
everything I can to raise the money
upfront not to have a lot of debt or
investment oftentimes on these films so
that when we get to market on a film
everybody's gonna start to see some cash
and it may not come across as quickly as
they want you never know how well a film
will do but I think that's been a pretty
cool approach to get people invested in
me you know invested in or the prop of
the film the product that we're
eventually going to deliver so there
they go so but yeah I mean I think it's
it's it's it's it's definitely tough
sometimes though because I think people
have such a jaded perspective of what
film it filmmaking is once they've been
inside for a while it's not easy you
know there's oftentimes not much money
and and so you've got to find ways to to
really get people to believe in you and
and I found that by making multiple
films and just sticking with this course
of action and not trying to be too
elaborate and not trying to aim too high
and you know keeping budgets low enough
and everything that people people
respect that and they see that you know
it can actually eventually turn a profit
which but say most of my films you're
doing now
you know we need when you factor in
sweat it's hard to say exactly how
profitable they are but ultimately I
mean the films are paying back all the
all the costs and getting that point
where you can distribute you know people
share to them and it tends to keep the
people that I've worked with that I
really respect you know coming back and
helping me again
you know and and there's a few key
players for sure that you'll need when
you make films like making sure you find
somebody who can do great music you know
it's always such a huge part of story
whether you were creating it from making
an original music or sourcing you know
music that's already made out there
that's been really important and I'm you
know fortunate enough recently to have
found a guy that I really like who I
can't just go back to him be like hey I
need this and he trusts me and knows
that like I can't necessarily pay him
sometimes like when I'm in that moment
of like I gotta get this film done and
packaged and out but eventually that
that paycheck will come hunter how is
financing for your five films evolved
from the first one to know okay so for
my first film 10 miles per hour we
financed it large part with credit cards
both Josh and I said we can't find any
sponsors we don't know where the money's
at put a lot of work into that but a lot
of energy into trying to get you know
other people to help fund the film and
really blanked out so we just took our
credit cards and financed it and we got
to a point in the process where we
needed to tap in a little bit of our
retirement savings which was nice that I
had that available casinos you know some
people don't and and it's interesting
because people are always so afraid to
spend their retirement but I found that
really a freeing activity like
ultimately it's been a great way to use
that investment ultimately further my
life and my experiences which I think
should be the right thing so that was 10
miles per hour we it was tough we took a
lot of our own you know money and just
dumped it in and said we've got to get
this thing done and we've got to make it
and put it out to the market eventually
over the course of time with 10 miles
per hour the money that we did the hard
cash that we actually spent on our our
credit cards and retirement was was
returned to us so that was that was cool
all the sweat they probably never
totally got paid back but it's nice to
know that the film is still generating
some revenue almost you know eight years
or so after its release so it's pretty
cool second film 10-yards
we were actually at this point in time
able to start looking at some
sponsorships and we were able to close
some sponsorships but it was pretty
limited I'm
we were talking fifteen to twenty
thousand dollars somewhere in that range
of cash that we raised but it took quite
a bit of edge off with making the film
by this time I we had some of the camera
equipment already you know we've
invested some of that early money and to
sort of building a program there was
also some additional cash that was put
in as sort of an investment from from an
individual and so that was again we were
in a place where all of a sudden there
was a little bit of money but we didn't
quite have enough money to really round
it out get the film done and then have
enough left over for a launch so we were
you know burning all of the cash on
production which is probably the biggest
challenge I think filmmakers face is we
get a little bit of money some somehow
or another you know and we blow it all
to make this film and then you're in
this situation or we're okay with the
film's made a lot of times people blow
it all before they edit it you know and
then that's a really difficult position
to be in so I think you know you really
got to think that through and divvy it
up and let people know early off that
it's gonna be a long time before they
probably see money so with 10 yards
unfortunately because we were putting
all of all of the money that we we
received from these sponsorships and
this individual we were putting all into
you know making the film and and trying
to market the film we ended up spending
more money of our own and getting a
little bit further into debt so after
that film I was that I was on a tough
place couldn't figure out how to make
any money off that film it just it was
just my sophomore slump and it was a
really tough one so we're moving on to
my third film ride the divide I you know
figuring things out I'm realizing okay
sponsorships man I know I can make these
work better by this time I had two
examples and I could sort of paint 10
yards as a success to the sponsors when
we went out to try to get money so I
worked with Mike Dion on this and we
went out and we actually raised quite a
bit of sponsorship money I'd say I want
to say around 50 grand and then there
was again private investment put into
that film probably equal amount and
private investment so we actually had a
nice chunk of money
that was put in that film because we got
closer to release there was another
little bit of investment that came in to
finish it up
and so that film was great because it
was an we were in a situation where
there was there was always cash but we
were very smart about not overspending
cash and really most of that money is
going into production not really paying
people it's going into travel it's going
into you know the aspects of
post-production where you really need to
hire expertise like sound and color
correction and just finishing the film
and getting it really solid you know
being amplified product and things like
that so you can sell the film so we had
a great situation where when that film
was done there wasn't too much of that
you know money to pay back there's a
little bit I think there was a little
bit of debt still debt / investment that
was put into that film and so we were
able to pay that off quickly because the
film was was really successful and had
you know missed by Pharma but my most
most most profitable film so far that
I've worked on and it's you know it
continues to do really well and that
that film released three or four years
ago I think about three three and half
and it's still doing really well so it's
pretty cool because it's like we passed
that mark now it creates a revenue
stream that I try to figure out ways not
to use but you know inevitably I do at
times to to make sure I further this
further my career I keep reinvesting in
my films so moving on to the fourth film
that was where the yellow stone goes
which it was made in tandem with another
film called the reveal the path and I
have some ownership in each of those
films so kind of talk about both of
those together essentially where the
yellow stone goes was able to raise
about seventy five thousand in
sponsorship money this is coming from
basically corporate brands or not or
nonprofit one nonprofit for for
corporate brands and they put money into
the film because they liked the message
that's that told we found ways to create
some ancillary content and just kind of
help you know use the film to drive at
some of the messages they're trying to
communicate and reach the same audience
then we were also able to raise some
crowdfunding money
the time that film was finished and
ready for market which helped it go to
market we took all the money we raised
some crowdfunding and put it into
pushing the film further out there and
getting more screening set up which is
scary to do because you're like you work
so hard you're like oh I've sudden we
got $32,000 the bank and you're like
this is great it's payday but but we
look at it and we're like it's not you
just it's on us to keep putting those
money in there one way or another and so
that films done also done really well
and it was nice that the minute it went
to market for the most part I mean it
took a there's a little bit maybe to pay
off for like a month or two but like it
was like basically instant instant money
we're able to give back to the partners
and the creators at the same time we
made reveal the path which I got they
got more investment than sponsorship it
got a little bit of sponsorship not as
much as where the yellow stone goes I
can't say the exact figure but you know
it's less than 75,000 and but it got
also quite a bit of infusion of
investment it was a highly intensive
like travel around the world film where
we went to five different countries and
shot and so we're dealing with a more
expensive film than where the yellow
stone goes and so in the end that film
went to market and had a lot of money to
pay back and we're still important
paying that film back so that's just
kind of an example of how you gotta
weigh all these things and be careful if
you can if you can raise some money and
really be careful about how you spend
that money and then you know try to get
partners creative creative partners on
board who will benefit later you can get
to that that money coming in quicker and
then finally Walter Walter was is a very
low-budget film a lot of sweat for both
my wife and I was it's kind of a
collaborative project where we came
together as we were getting married and
made this film and so we had some
investment about $35,000 in investment
to make the film we use that cash and
then raised 25,000 for its release I put
a lot of sweat and got some some friends
to help us out so we've got our getting
our creative partner strategy
we're now releasing it with not too much
debt we have some investment but that's
part of the it kind of balances out with
the creative partners as well so I mean
we hope that by next year or you know
early next year depending on how fast we
push the release because we've been
thinking about kind of taking time but
we hope that film is paying everybody
back you know soon so it seems to be
working you know but it's and keep in
mind that that Walter actually started
before where the yellow stone goes so it
kind of kind of fits in there and and
ultimately where the yellow stone goes
let has led to it another film a whole
River series and one of the sponsors
that was involved with that doubled
their commitment to the next film and it
tends to do a series of more river films
with us so we're doing sort of the same
sort of strategy where we keep a
documentary that is essentially low cash
budget high sweat budget and in the end
has a has a quicker payout for the
people that are involved that are
committed and take the chance so from
your years of approaching corporate
sponsors what would you tell someone
what's the first step what do they want
to see what should you not say so
corporate sponsorship is a tough one
because if you've never made a film
before you haven't done anything to sort
of prove your potential you can't just
convince a corporate sponsor or brand
you know or a non-profit or somebody
like that to give you a bunch of money
there they're being approached all the
time for all of these different you know
opportunities but with that being said
you got to realize they they're trying
to do many of the things that we're
trying to do with our films which is
reach people they need to they need to
figure out how to create messages and
have stories that really that really
kind of drive at what their brand is and
so I've found you know if you have a
film that has you know some some
definition of sort of a story or a brand
or kind of a strong niche you can often
find ways to give some additional cash
or assistance I think that it's
important you know if you're going at it
the first time you don't have a body of
work to find somebody that does to find
a way to build up your team and and your
your documentary so or your film that
you're making so that you can find a way
to say hey let's get this this this
company I'm involved and they'll take us
more seriously it's pretty easy to
attach a name of a producer or you know
or director or store an actor or
somebody like this business is all about
that unfortunately you need that sort of
expertise on something so it's gotten
easier for me as that went cuz I've had
multiple films and I can set them down
right in front of them that being said I
also think you've got to have a story
for your own story that you're trying to
tell and that story needs to match with
that company's sort of approach you know
needs to fit in or it needs to surprise
them and excite them and make them go oh
okay that's that's the way it is it's
changing so fast like when I first went
out it was easy to kind of show like
this online video world was just coming
on and I could kind of give them a sense
of how we'll be able to you
maybe create some additional content and
maybe you know tie their brand into some
of the you know the DVD extras but also
some of the online extras you know there
were certain ways that I could give
their brand some presents and and
ultimately you know make them feel like
it was a worthwhile investment and they
get that return I'm finding you know
even the partners that I've worked with
now are coming back to me and going well
this is really cool what you guys are
doing and your films are really getting
out there and they're all over Netflix
and all these people you know but
they're still trying to figure out
they're always trying to figure how to
quantify if it is if they're making good
investments and marketing out there it's
such one of those ambiguous areas it's
always hard to tell so I think the more
data you can offer when you go out to
pitch to brands or or nonprofits the
better but you also have to kind of have
a plan like how is this going to really
help you know help an entity that is
trying to serve its people how you can
help them ultimately reach reach their
goals with what you're trying to put out
there and there's a lot of ways I mean
when you when you look around I'd say
definitely have a nice little
presentation not very you don't have to
make it very long but at least a sheet
or two that really kind of looks good
spells out you know how how this film is
gonna help the brand have some region
it's not just about like product
placement or you know putting a logo on
a website or logo on a box I mean
there's so many ways now that the
brand's are you know and nonprofits are
trying to sort of work with through
authentic stories to ultimately better
what they're they're trying to do and
their cause so
I've I've personally made it a point to
try to work with brands that I like and
and that kind of relate to to the nature
of my films I like to inspire people to
live fuller lives so for me I I focused
on trying to trying to look for
companies that are similar and I could
tell my own personal story when I sit
down in a in an office and talk to
somebody so so I think that's important
is to kind of just think about that that
approach is you go out there is fine
brands that are like you find nonprofits
that are like you that are like your
film and and start from there
you know like these they're people that
work for these brands and represent but
represent these brands are just like us
and I think if you can kind of go in and
build a relationship they'll be more
interested in supporting your your your
film your idea your story and that takes
time like people you can just like
making a film you can't just go make a
film you can't just go throw a one film
out there you really have to say okay
I'm gonna start to get to know these
companies and you know you know you
can't just like ride them and say hey
I've got this film and I need you know
$20,000 $50,000 or whatever you've got
to really you know try to get an
introduction through the right person if
you can't you know if you can't you can
use the LinkedIn and various other ways
to try to find the right people who work
for a company and marketing or PR and
really just try to present your case
this is I've got something that's really
really compelling here and I've got the
newfangled way to do it and I'm
connected to these people and here's how
you know how we're gonna do it I
wouldn't go too fast into that sale but
ultimately when you sit down with them
you've got to convince them that you
know you've got you've got something
that's gonna do a lot for them and this
is a great time for that still because I
think that there's so much content out
there and brands are trying to figure
out how to separate themselves a little
bit be be unique and work with the true
creators you know not just the
advertising agencies ultimately though
after advertise the eight advertising
agencies have a lot of control over this
stuff creative agencies as well so
that's difficult when you start dealing
with big brands they're ultimately going
to go to do they trust and so you might
have to take a
for an approach it's one area that I've
just kind of avoided you know I just
I've just figured I could put a lot of
energy into that and a lot of us do but
you just get get beat down so I kind of
you know that's so that's one of those
limitations
maybe I'm sending it too much for myself
but I won't go too much after the big
Nikes or the big Coca Cola's there's a
big big brands they usually focus on
these smaller kind of mid tier you know
small small companies or mid-sized
companies that that might might be more
apt to listen to me so let's suppose
it's just a cold call that you're gonna
make maybe you don't have a relationship
maybe you're not gone LinkedIn with them
would you actually pick up the phone and
call them would you send them an email
what would be your approach how long is
your message to them yeah generally when
I'm first approaching a brand or there
are some kind of a partner you know
because there's many other types of
companies nonprofits even individuals
sometimes that that can that can help a
film and give you know give some money
to it but I'll usually start with email
I usually look online try to get to know
them I might start with a quick email
just you know saying I'd love to talk
with you I've got a problem and idea
film there's something that I'm working
on in development with and I try not to
make it too lengthy you know two or
three sentences because everybody's
jamming hard and they get into stuff and
when they get this long spiel and pitch
it's like they don't even want to look
at it they just want to move on to their
next email or their other thing they got
to do it just it just feels like a lot
of work when you see a lot of words on a
page so I try I start short and a lot of
times gonna follow up and follow up and
I'll make a phone call you know every
once in a while I do call like a main a
main phone number at you know at a
company I was actually thinking about
approaching Smuckers for Walter because
they sponsor the hundred
hundred-year-old birthdays with Willard
Scott on on The Today Show and so I was
like well I was trying to figure out how
to put this together and you know
truthfully I just didn't find the time
you had to do that but you know my
approach there would have been
I can call Smuckers and and see who
would be best to talk to in their PR
department or their market department
once you give them an idea they'll often
give you an email or you know patch you
through to somebody who can leave them a
quick message you know and then it's
just a matter of starting to have
conversations and usually they'll want
to see it a deck or propose like a
proposal
you know she want Purple's over some
bullet points but I wouldn't spend too
much time like you know you know
stressing over that stuff like
definitely get some some ideas put
together and you know I have some good
Burbage and you know you know kind of
spent some time tweaking and see what
works and doesn't work but over time you
can you'll find that some B's people
will be honest with you and you'll get a
sense of what they want or what they
don't want and hopefully you get to the
point where you're closing some money
you know I mean there's a you're always
gonna get so many things like we've
already spent our budget or no this just
doesn't really line up with our strategy
this year you know really focused on
this thing or that thing you know and I
find that those are you know usually
quick ways to get rid of you but at the
same time they're probably true
you know if you hear that go okay well
if they're saying that what can I derive
from that maybe there's maybe there's
some insight or some clue and then of
course you can start to look around for
people that know somebody cuz a lot of
times when you get somebody who knows
someone you're gonna get much further
much faster if you're introduced or if
you're even able just to say hey I was
talking with Nancy who happens to be
your good friend the other day and Nancy
said I should you know talk with you
about this and that she's really excited
about this project I'm working on maybe
maybe you might be too well instantly
there's like there it's so much more
receptive so it's just kind of trying to
find that little now a little game to
get them to care and to spend some time
and then ultimately once you're in like
they've got to just believe in you you
got to be real you know you can't you
can't be too fake and very used to
sniffing out lots of fake proposals that
aren't gonna I don't gonna really go
anywhere so a bit of energy definitely
block off some time to to really go for
it and don't get it don't give up
because it will take time it's you're
gonna make a lot of calls and put out a
lot of emails before you start to see
any check
at what point those should someone move
on to the next sponsor I mean if you've
left numerous messages do you still take
that as a maybe in your mind no I move
on I probably give up too soon too many
times I definitely you know it's one of
those things we're in the process of
raising money right now for a film
called coming clean and we have the
initial money in and that's closed and
that's been great but we have a lot of
different sort of possibilities but
they're all just sort of lingering so
it's getting easier now to at least get
people not to just like to listen to a
pitch you know and then they're sort of
like hanging in there like oh this
sounds good we've got a number of
sponsors that are hanging in the sort of
wings waiting they haven't committed but
they're interested and we were finding
that it's easier to get these sponsors
to to listen to our national pitch and
and so I find like with that though it's
like you know I'll follow up to a
certain point but then I just have to
keep going on and I realized that maybe
if they're not committing anything that
they're not they're not interested but
so much of this is about educating them
like when you're starting to talk to
smaller companies that aren't that don't
have whole departments that deal with
these types of proposals you really have
to be able to get it and that's why you
can get somewhere if you spend the time
to educate them and help them realize
that you know these films are reaching
their audience these films these films
are these projects a lot of times it's
not just a film it's a multimedia
experience transmedia you know different
you know you know level of content
that's ultimately going to you know hit
their audience in a way that they can't
hit them by just throwing ads all over
the place you know that's what a lot of
these places are trying to do you know
they're really trying to they're also
trying to develop the audience so I
think if you can kind of figure out what
we're doing and match it to you know
where some of the money's at
you can also really make make make make
it go far you know and it's one of those
areas that like I don't spend too much
time in just because if you get I think
if you get too much corporate money or
nonprofit money it does tend to put a
damper on your creative space you know I
definitely have felt that pressure from
small
where I've got money and you know I do
the best I can to serve them but
ultimately I'm gonna focus primarily on
making sure that the the the main
feature comes together and is solid and
I've seen many a sponsors get worried
and watch that happen and they're like
okay this is my investment and where is
this or that and in the end they're
happy of course if the film does well
but also in the end they don't really
know a lot of times they're just moving
on to their next priorities and they
don't even care and they're just it's
it's a weird process because that you
know that you would think that they'd
want to put more into helping the film
do well but they're they're done once
they give you some money they move on
and and that's not always a bad thing
either but you kind of hope that you
find sponsors or partners that are also
gonna help push that film out into the
world
that's beautiful when you have that you
know this is sort of this double
advantage of like cash coming in that
you don't have to pay back you pay back
in different ways because usually
there's content or or something that you
give up for it but but then at the end
they're also going to their huge
database of people that potentially are
like-minded and helping spread the film
out there for you hunter while working
on Walter what was the worst moment and
what was that one time when you pretty
much thought you were going to be just
done pull the plug on it so with Walter
I knew that I'd alternately finish the
film in some capacity but I think - for
me the hardest part of the filmmaking
process now is getting to that point
where you're letting it go and getting
it out there and not because I have to
let it go and that's really difficult
because I don't know what people are
gonna think and this and that and that's
a little bit you know you push people
gonna judge you but like I'm dealing
with the same old old industry out there
and I still give it so much power like
all of these people that try to shape
things and try to say this is the way
you should do it and you have to you
have to do these windows and all this
crap is garbage it's like you know in
this day and age we can do whatever we
want and we should be doing that and and
the times that I do that I do very well
but with Walter you know
like okay I'm gonna go through the
traditional traditional film festival
channel again and try to get this into
Sundance for the umpteenth time and it's
like and I'm you know and this time I'm
gonna spend you know spend a little
extra time and energy and try to get in
touch with a few of the the key stake
like the key programmers there are the
people that might that might care you
know and and you go through that and you
realize well but something they don't
care about us
you know they just have they have
there's so much out there and there's so
much money and there's so many places
all around the world that are trying to
produce content trying to buy for that
attention that you start to realize just
how crowded this market is and how how
difficult that is but that gets me
frustrated because I feel like I've paid
my dues you know and I think so many of
us get there it's like God you know
paint our dues we've done this why can't
I catch a break so for Walter the
hardest moment for me it was like when
we got our rough cut done and we started
thinking wow this is a really cool film
that everybody should care about even
though we did it in a low-grade way it's
just it's so important we're all humans
were all gonna grow old and die very
soon before we know it and it goes fast
and we're all you know you get to a
chance to talk to these people from way
back when they were born in the 1800s
and it's like it's just something was so
special to me but that's how we all feel
we get so we get so invested personally
in our own thing so so when you start to
go out and you you go hey Sundance hey
South by what do you think of this film
and then they just deject you you know
it's like hmm it's it's a it's a tough
it's a tough moment to have happen over
and over again but the best part is and
I've done it every time I turn right
around and I go out there and I make I
make my things count and I continue to
have a career and I have people reaching
out to me that love my my work now
enough that they you know potentially
want to bring me in as a creator on a on
a on a television series or as a you
know as somebody who's gonna help lead
another documentary or that they're
gonna you know put some of their
company's money into a project that I do
because it gets out there and more
importantly it's like you look at
Netflix and there's 45,000 ratings on a
film you know
or more and you go God like all these
people are watching this and like taking
the time to put these you know put these
stars and you know give you give you
feedback and sometimes right you like
notes and say hey this is awesome keep
at it so what I realize is that's who
matters that's what that's what it's all
about it has we should not we should not
be so focused on this old-school
industry that's built up that's making
so many people frustrated you know so
that's pretty much it keep after it
Hunter when you were planning your
crowdfunding campaign for Walter did you
think that you would end up with the
four hundred and sixty one backers that
you did I have to say when I set out to
do the Kickstarter with Sarah we were we
were nervous about it we felt like we
had a good shot of being successful but
we also knew from the first my first
experience with it that it's so much
work and if you want to be successful
you've got to really stay on it and be
on it and I was a little nervous because
I knew this topic that we were dealing
with was not cycling and not fishing and
not something that really closely
matched one of the previous films in
essence it's similar it's got some of
the same themes and concepts of living
life well and and they live a full happy
life you know but we set out and we said
we're gonna go for it and and we always
tell ourselves we're just gonna make
sure it's successful we're gonna do
everything we can not to fail and and we
were lucky on this one because it just
started to hit fast and hit right one of
the things that happened for us where we
really got lucky and I think this comes
with having a nice shaped
pitch for for your for your story is
that a kickstarter recognized as a
project of the day pretty early in the
process and we actually saw that
generating quite a bit of attention from
people we didn't know so that gave us a
lot of internal enthusiasm and really
kind of give us that feeling like wow
people are gonna like this film you know
like that's a good thing so gave us you
kind of need that in energy we
definitely found as usual you need to
hit your own friends many
times and I'm not saying like what
happens is Facebook sort of hides it
from everybody so you have to like trick
the algorithms you have to keep keep
posting and eventually it does reach
people towards the very end of the
campaign because we're like well I
didn't hear anything about this I want
you know like they were surprised and I
was like how did that people not hear
about this I'm sitting there like
paranoid I'm PBS styling it like crazy
like just pitching pitching pitching
pitching and I'm like people are gonna
defriend me but you have to kind of do
that not worry about it and go hey this
is what we do like we make these film
then there's not a lot of support forum
in the United States especially and you
know the only way that we're going to
truly get this thing out there finish up
this process is if the friends and fans
that we've had before come come back and
support us again and and fortunately you
know they did a lot of a lot of the 461
were people that have found us along the
way on different film projects and it's
really kind of neat because I'll see
somebody pop on I'll be like who gives a
little bit of money on I'm like ah
that's a guy that first started talking
to me during 10 miles per hour
and I obviously you know I try my
hardest to try to stay connected online
whatever with people that are really
reaching out to me you know I don't see
why we shouldn't be so it's kind of neat
to see that sort of process happen but
it takes a ton of work you know it's a
combination of QA and email if you have
an email database you definitely got to
be emailing and usually that's really
effective social media the times it
works times a dozen you know you gotta I
spend a little bit of money with
Facebook boosting some of my posts you
know I'm not afraid to do that I know
that I don't you know appreciate the way
that I sometimes feel like you get
blocked out less you spend money but you
got it I mean it wasn't a huge amount of
money for what I think the return was
you know Twitter it's it's one of those
in miss things you gotta you know just
keep peppering it out there and and then
I you know I find like posting images
there's certain tricks of the social
media you can look all those up to kind
of try to get social media like
impressions a little higher and that's
important it's amazing how that the sort
of dorky things like share this you put
you put share this on a image or
something like that maybe a little quote
from Walter and it just starts to go you
know like so many people share it and I
mean I shouldn't discredit that I
appreciate people doing that but it's
like it's funny cuz to me it feels sort
of hokey and in
insincere not authentic and you know
sometimes wish those more authentic
things would go but but ultimately we
were really happy with that for 6661 and
i remember we were looking at each other
as it went on and were like what if we
get to 400 that'd be so cool I think we
had 372 backers with Yellowstone so for
us as we got past that 372 mark it was
less about the money it was more about
the backers we were like this is cool
like more and more people are taking a
few minutes to like really buy into and
many times not just a few minutes but
you know several like quite a bit of
money to you know to really buy into
this project and help support it and see
it see it play itself out so it's pretty
cool and one of the things you do you
know and crowdfunding is you're kind of
looking at your peers you're looking at
other films out there York I like to
analyze a lot try to figure out like
okay is this real money like are they
are they jacking it up so how and that's
always the goal of ours with this
campaign were like we do not want to
have to find a friend to top it off at
the end and get us to that hump or you
know and whatnot and so it was it was
pretty cool to just sit back and and
trust the process to work and and work
very hard to help it work and and and
heave a huge sigh of relief when we
could stop badgering everybody and take
our PBS campaign off the airwaves and
just let it be you know so what happened
when you hit and I love this to the
sophomore slump because I mean every
campaign it seems like they take off
like a rocket some of them at least and
then you hit that low so what were you
doing during that time what were you
doing Sara up to so we hit our sort of
midterms long soft sophomore slump
probably about 10 15 days into the
campaign and it was like up to that
point it was we were averaging over a
thousand a day I mean I are something
like that I mean we were like fifteen
sixteen thousand when we hit that low
and we're like we're so close it's like
for that but then you're like $4,000
that's a lot of money like you start
seeing you know $20 here and then you
don't get a donation till you know that
night and it's you know $7 like I'd be
like it's big we're not gonna get there
all in seven so it's like we really felt
the impact of that lull by that time the
infant's the the energy that Kickstarter
helped bring into the
- the experience had gone away you know
it's amazing online if your top shelf
thought a film like when when Netflix
moves us out - top shelf and features
one of our titles there's a lot of
people to see that movie over a short
period of time we get emails we see
sales go up say same thing with
Kickstarter when you're top shelf on
Kickstarter on these digital platforms
it's like that's the name of the game
how do you get a top shut top shelf you
know but you see that happen it's like
it's awesome but then when you're on
your own you know you feel like of
course the hit our little lull and I
think our friends and family everybody
like we're looking at this going yeah
these guys are gonna hit their their
$20,000 goal and then so it took we
tried to like put it out of our mind and
not put as much energy into it but you
still can't help it you're like oh maybe
I should be pushing more and of course
your dreams are starting to fade of
going above your 20 you know your goal
and you're like oh you can you start
doing the math and you're like we really
need a lot more to do what we tell
everybody we're doing here we're trying
to launch me an Academy qualifying film
bid which means we've got a you know get
New York a full week in New York a full
week in LA and spend all this money and
it's like it starts mounting in your
mind so eventually you know we did take
a few days off and then and then we just
kind of found a way to finish strong and
we've launched a you know the big thing
is doing sort of a stretch goal now but
we didn't do one stretch goal we did
these small mini stretch goals and we
actually announced new theatrical
locations that we'd be able to play if
we hit those goals so like 21,000 was
Great Falls and which is Mother's
hometown and then 22,000 was Seattle and
Portland or something like that so we
were able to like kind of start to build
out our our launch presence beyond Los
Angeles and New York with these many
goals and we were able to get all the
goals done except for the last one we
had one last one which was $5,000 to do
a little UK Europe you know to her but
we knew that one was a real stretch so
we were totally happy without turned out
and as you know I'm just thankful that
we got it done so
we understand that you want to qualify
Walter for the Oscars and there's a very
set process is that right what what is
that process and what are you doing so
we had a chance with Walter when we were
getting ready to release it we were like
well just take to qualify for an Academy
Award you know how do they decide who
wins an Academy there's got to be
something you go through so we just went
online and looked at their website and
they have a very extensive list of rules
for various types that you got in there
to feature if you've got a in our case
the documentary feature the rules are
different from what you'd need for
documentaries short or a short narrative
or foreign film and so we started to
read through them and I was as I was
reading them I'm like well it's not as
difficult as you might think
I know that they're making it you know
be something that they don't don't want
just any film like any you know
low-grade film that's made kind of cast
out to but they so they do qualify some
things that cost some money and
essentially these are all sort of change
from time to time
but at the current moment for a
documentary feature you have to screen
commercially for a week in New York and
Los Angeles and these are minimum
requirements so they're definitely
looking for you to do more as much as
possible with film so when you when we
talk about New York they're talking
about Manhattan borough so you gotta be
in the big city with you know all the
other films that come out every week
there's something like 20 plus films
that are launched every weekend in New
York and you've got to have reviews in
New York and also reviews on the west
coast in in proper newspapers like the
New York Times which becomes fairly easy
to do if you have a commercial release
in New York because as of right now it's
the New York Times policy to review
films their release for a week there I
have over the years trying to get New
York Times and Carrie it's like bigger
periodicals to review my films than they
don't because of this particular you
know factor they have so many
they basically review only once movie
released commercially so in addition to
releasing commercially on a documentary
you have to send the Academy 250 DVDs
and that those go out to their
nomination committees who decide who is
who decide Alton Ellie what's going to
be nominated and those DVDs cannot have
any artwork on them as we found the hard
way we actually have a DVD that was
designed with a for your consideration
cover on it and it's only textured which
we didn't consider art but it was art
ultimately it was not just blank or you
know not art and so fortunately there
there they've been very considering
they're working with us you know at each
of the stages here and so we have a
quick solution of sending some envelopes
that they'll stuff for us it's kind of
interesting to see all of these little
pieces and parts you also have to
advertise in new york and la minute very
minimal requirements there but you do
have to have at least one ad in a couple
of newspapers before your premieres
and you have to have a certain amount of
screenings and they have to be between
certain period of time those are the
basic requirements to be able to qualify
a film for the for the academy and of
course you send in some paperwork inside
signed some stuff no money is required
in order to qualify other than making
your commitment to get your film out
commercially and that's definitely like
for most production companies is is you
know a huge undertaking and cost quite a
bit I should say too that you have
cannot have screened your film anywhere
before it goes into a theater and has
its you know its release I believe it
can okay I believe it could have
screamed at like film festivals but it
can't
you know it has to have its it's world
for me it can't be commercially
available you know as a as a digital
download or as a DVD before you go into
theaters and have you looked at prior
like I'm thinking of in assente I think
was was not last year's or it was I just
saw the trailer and it looked so amazing
but have you looked at some of the other
success stories with that and tried to
kind of see what they've done all right
I don't know I'm just wondering what
kind of background research do you do
before you make such a time commitment
and money I'm sure you know I'm I'm kind
of a shoot-from-the-hip guy a lot of
times to just get a hunch and I go with
it and so in this particular instance I
didn't really do a ton of research you
know I definitely saw their campaigns I
read about campaigns that felt like it
wasn't worth the costs to nominate or to
allow film to be to be considered for
nomination to qualify I I actually
looked at it as it was part of our
Kickstarter campaign we wanted people to
be able to help us give us that
opportunity because besides the
opportunity to be qualified it was the
opportunity to play in New York I've
never played for a week in New York
never played for a week in LA you know
God open in sort of a commercial theater
in this manner a lot of times my films
are going on theatrical tours sometimes
I'm with them we're playing in all kinds
of different places
lots of theaters I've definitely spent
money in in like outdoor towns at big
theaters like the Boulder Theatre which
is very expensive to rent for one night
you know to launch a film but but I
never had this sort of traditional film
release and I felt after ten years I
felt personally I deserved it and so I I
it was one of those moments where I said
I'm gonna do it and I want to get this
film out there it's a film that I don't
think has a lot of chances of getting a
nomination personally just based on what
I've seen out there that's been
nominated but I think it's a terribly
important film you know I got a chance
to spend time with these be
they're incredible and I think if people
see the film for what it's supposed to
be you know if they really get it
they'll see the way that we have sort of
captured their lives and in kind of
context to you know Sarah in my life as
we come together and I think you know I
think that there's so many people that
sort of miss the things that matter in
life and I try to like in my films I try
to put that out there and so when I when
I think about what we tried to do and I
don't know if we achieved it yet cuz we
haven't seen how it plays out you know
it's something that personally I feel
like why not why can't they why can't
this potentially be recognized by the
Academy you know who judges what what in
the cat you know Academy nominated film
should be so we figured we'd give it a
shot and we can never look back and say
we did it and now we know the process
and it's not that scary but it's
expensive I mean I I guess you're gonna
sink if you go for the very minimum
which I think that they prefer you to do
more than a very minimum and you're
gonna sink probably $25,000 at least
into it which is you know where we hit
with Kickstarter interestingly enough
but if you want to really support your
launch
and you're gonna open commercially in
New York and LA and and potentially
other theaters I mean you really want to
probably be thinking like 50 to 75
thousand dollars you know depending on
who you need to hire or how much you can
or can't handle a publicist for example
they're not cheap and we try to do a lot
of our own publicity in different ways
but you know for this release of Walter
we went ahead and hired a publicist and
I started calling around and trying to
get publicist to consider the film and
and it was difficult you know there was
a lot of that new york-based publicist
that you hear about and you meet when
you go to places like conferences like
South by Southwest and they won't even
consider you know your your films
because they've never heard of you or
you're too small or or whatnot but but
those that do like I mean they'll
they'll they'll quote you like 4,000 or
5,000 for a release in New York and then
you know a few more thousand dollars for
release their release in LA you know
you're looking at you know that kind of
money for a few weeks of someone's time
to open utley go out and push your film
to the press and it sounds like a lot of
money but if you don't work with those
types of people and you work with
somebody who's a lot lesser they don't
necessarily have those types of
connections to where they can make a
phone call to somebody at the New York
Times that they sort of know so they
know they can ultimately maybe get you
know some favorable press for your film
that being said you never know like you
can spend all that money and get nothing
we decided to go for someone who was in
the heart of the documentary world at in
New York she works very closely with
stranger than fiction Doc series by Tom
powers and doc NYC Film Festival and so
she really had a lot of connections and
kind of helped helped us build a
grassroots game out there and and it was
just a really great personality a really
wonderful person and she's worked very
hard on the film and and but I don't
think she had has yet quite those really
big powerhouse connections which in the
way we kind of like because that's where
we're at and she just matched who we
were and that she matched the way we we
feel about things and when you can be
okay with that and be a piece of that
and not not worry too much that you're
not necessarily gonna get that you know
the hundreds of huge articles so
whatever you know you kind of you kind
of let it beat but it's it's always a
little tough cuz you're spending quite a
bit of money on PR and you don't really
know what it's going to do for you
what would you say the bulk of the
25,000 that you raised for Walter on
Kickstarter was spent on so the bulk of
the the money raised on Kickstarter was
definitely spent on this Academy
qualifying campaign and specifically the
commercial releases in New York and LA
there are ways to four-wall commercial
release and we are four for long our
commercial release so it's just tough
because you walk into LA New York in our
specific case it's gonna be a little
different depending on if you're getting
daytime slots or evening slots but as of
right now I mean it's you know you're
looking at probably $12,000 to $20,000
somewhere in that range in order to be
able to secure those two locations for
one week and and you're talking anywhere
I mean you're talking like 14 to 21
screenings at each location for that
kind of money so if you got a film
that's not gonna get a lot of audience
and we know going into it we're not
gonna get a ton on its doing it you're
not gonna see much of that money come
back that's just money that poops away
but that money comes back in interesting
ways and this gets back to the idea of
investing for the long-term thinking
about the long-term and this is an
experiment so I can't speak for sure
about this but my feeling is by giving
the film a little bit of a bigger richer
context from the beginning sort of
polishing it up and having it be this
type of film that has reviews whether
they're good or not you know it's got
these reviews it's got bigger press and
it will ultimately help shape the film
for some bigger sales down the road so I
think that money will come back that's
my prediction
and we'll you know I'm happy to check
back with you guys but it's pretty scary
when you're like you know write these
checks and you go well shoot for you
know $15,000 I could put on a heck of a
good tour and go to places where we know
we could probably fill the theaters
and make all that money back and more
and then put that to the film to go
forward but you'll get a bunch of
reviews and like small towns like Great
Falls which are great they always feel
really good but they don't necessarily
speak to the film industry and allow you
this film you know the film based
opportunities where people want the film
and help sell it further on down the
road
so when you were calling these theaters
in LA and New York were you going based
on price or were you going based on
which ones actually had ends with
getting those reviews in the New York
Times all the times what was your
strategy so our strategy when we set up
our commercial releases in New York and
LA was first to kind of research and see
if other people had done this which
which they had so I started to realize
there's actually people that will help
broker the deal for you so if you google
around ya you'll find somebody who can
kind of help you and it's all part of a
package price
I actually went direct to IFC Center and
said hey I cuz I've seen in an article
IFC Center helps films qualify for
Academy Awards meaning they will book a
book a film at a four wall price for you
know for a week meaning you don't have
to go through this weird convoluted
system I still haven't figured out to
get a book or to consider your film to
get it out there you know I starting to
realize as I do this more and more it is
very controlled by the studios or the
distributors that have the money to
market these films so for somebody
that's you know smaller and has smaller
films and doesn't necessarily have a ton
of money for PA it's gonna be very
difficult for you to get like
conventional theatrical releases out
there but there are these smaller art
houses that are starting to realize that
in New York and LA and and for certain
kind of price you can get in so I went
to I have C Center first talk to talk to
a guy there about what it would cost and
he started to run some numbers and I
think it was like around you know 6500
for their lowest package which is
daytime daytime screenings you know you
have to be within a certain window to
qualify it has to be after one o'clock
sits not like 10 a.m. screenings but
it's still like you're talking about
like pretty early screenings you could
have all a 115 and a 315 screen
for your movie you know and that's your
trip the after : launch you know we're
in a situation where we're like well we
want an evening slot we want to
definitely have that evening feel for
the film and have you know some people
that we know in the industry and some of
some other people show up and see the
film so we negotiated we ended up
working with a guy in LA but set up
called IFC Center and and a theater
chain here called lammle that would you
know ultimately launch our film for you
know the right kind of times that we
liked so it paid a little little extra
to get some better times but I think
we're definitely happy to have done that
just have had that experience and you
know and and we actually used the
Kickstarter experience and brought it
back and we had we had people that that
contributed 200 dollars to be part of
our premieres out in in New York that
showed up and we got to meet these new
people and you know they became I think
hopefully deeper fans you know they it
seems that they were happy with the fact
that they put money and to help you make
this possible but that ultimately kind
of helped us feel like we could throw a
little bit of party and have a have a
fun launch out there in New York and so
that was pretty cool to see that see
that play itself out so you ultimately
did go with a Booker mm in the end yeah
we did
and they've been you know it's been an
interesting experience working with with
the Booker you know and you're kind of
trying to figure out the system and and
how they're talking about this or that
and you know we're dealing with
something now where they're trying to
switch us out possibly with a different
theater here it's that's a little bit
it's a little bit of a challenge
last-minute you know seeing seeing
seeing that happen and I don't know if
the Academy wants it that way who knows
you know that's something I'm curious
about I I've definitely toyed with the
idea of how how transparent like Sarah
and I are gonna be about here's what our
experience was like I mean it's
definitely been an up-and-down battle
it's been one of those things where it's
like man oh we should we really be
spending the money this way you know
it's certainly something we think about
but I I have convinced myself and I do
feel like it is nice to have a
legitimate release for a film and to put
the money into that but you know you do
there's a point where you have to think
about like if you're spending to you
know 15,000 plus all the other expenses
for
and all this other stuff so over $20,000
to do something but you're not really
seeing much money come back does that I
mean
economically doesn't make any sense in
that moment again we'll see down the
road with a little bit of smoke and
mirrors you never know you know and you
know somehow if if there was ever a
chance that we'd get nominated or even
shortlisted it would definitely give us
you know some attention and even if it
didn't present happen on this film but
maybe it introduces us to the right
people and helps us down the road on
another film you know maybe that was
that was a gamble that was worth it
so that's that's the way I look at it
you know I kind of looked back to the
Kickstarter moment this is what we told
people we're gonna do that's what we you
know that's what we built our campaign
around and we want to see it through so
well you know chalk it up to that and in
the end you didn't leave these jobs just
to make something and just put it up on
YouTube and there in the very end I mean
you you you want that pressed you want
that those two even if some of it is
smoke and mirrors which I've probably so
many filmmakers it is but still I mean
that's why you took that big leap and
that's why she did so I think that it's
probably hard in the moment to you know
it's easy to see those numbers but then
you don't know down the line it is hard
at the moment but there's there's that
point there's a those points in your
career where you shouldn't be afraid to
make those and sometimes that's leaving
the day job for a while like we talked
about earlier you know when I look look
at all these points where I've taken
risks like there's really not any time
where the patent go darn it why did I do
that you know sometimes it's hard in the
moment like I feel the difficulty of
spending all this money on this launch
but I realize like it's allowing me to
be here I'm taking as many meetings as I
can I'm you know reconnecting with many
filmmakers or many people in the
industry that I've known over the years
and so there's other ways where you see
the benefit of something or do it for
taking this this crazy action that's a
little scary you know though risky and
you never know how it's gonna how it's
gonna pan itself out right and sometimes
playing it safe can hurt someone yeah
you know yeah definitely I mean
there's many times when I'm timid and
shy and I play it safe and I'm like
nothing's happening well this is you
know you can just feel yourself becoming
a little less relevant so then you find
ways to to step it up and I'm just
grateful that I'm at a point where
there's a there is a crowd there's this
idea that people can come together and
help collectively you know help you take
that step you know have that confidence
I think of people you know continue to
approach it that way but not you know
you know not you know not abuse that I
mean it's something I take pretty
seriously if I'm raising money from
bands and friends and family like I want
to do everything I can to come through
for them and give them something awesome
and and I think unfortunately there's a
lot of people that probably don't don't
do that